Okay. So, welcome everyone to lecture
number six of the course
and let's more or less resume where we
stopped which is uh so the aim still
continues to be to learn PDEs or solve
PDEs using neural networks and the last
two lectures have shown us that using
physics informed neural networks this
just doesn't work. there are just too
many limitations out here. So the
solution that we proposed is to bring
data back into the equation somehow and
to focus on datadriven methods and in
this context uh what we discussed in the
last lecture was to use operator
learning. So this would be our main sort
of goal in the coming lectures including
today's lecture. So just to remind you
what is operator learning. So the idea
is that you have an operator. An
operator in general is a mapping between
infinite dimensional spaces. So you have
an operator, its input and outputs are
usually infinite dimensional functions,
sequences and so on. And just to make
things very concrete, so you think of a
PTE, let's just write some things. So
you imagine that you have a PDE. So D of
U this could be nonlinear equals F. So
the solution operator
and this is sort of the key object is
taking S no not S I think I called it as
G.
So G here is a mapping that takes F to
U. So necessarily these are function
spaces X going to Y. Right? So this is
the idea. So it's somehow the solution
of the PD is completely specified once
you have been given a solution operator
because then you change the input you
get a new solution you change the input
you get a new solution and so on.
Needless to say it's not the only
example of an operator. There are other
examples as we will see later on uh in
the course inverse operator. There are
other kinds of operators which show up
in science and engineering but for the
time being it is really the solution
operator of a PDE. it could be the
solution operator of an ordinary
differential equation. These are equally
valid. So that that's that's the whole
point, right? So we want to learn the
solution of the PTE or the solution
operator of the PD rather from data. And
as I said in the last lecture, the sort
of regime or the framework that we put
in place uh relied on having a
distribution mu which is a probability
measure on functions. We will see
concrete examples of that uh during the
course. So you have probability measures
on functions and then we are allowed to
draw samples. So in general you have
samples uh a a is what I used uh okay I
don't have changed this but a is your
input g of a is the output the solution
operator of the pd. So essentially you
change the input you have a new solution
of the pd and you put it in and then the
task of operator learning is to learn
this so-called push forward. So this
object is called a push ball is
essentially just taking inputs to the
PTE from this distribution sort of
mapping it forward through the solution
operator and learning the role of that
map. Right? So this is the aim of
operator learning. Uh
someone is saying can the slide be
shared on zoom
don't you see? Okay let's pause the
resume the recording. So this is what we
need to need to really learn right. So
now if you remember so essentially our
idea was that this is an infinite
dimensional problem and uh neural
networks. So if you take any neural
network these are mappings from some
higher dimensional space to another
higher dimensional space. So this is the
disconnect right this is the jasmine
that we wanted to bridge. So this object
is essentially infinite dimensional.
Neural networks are essentially finite
dimensional objects. The question is how
does one reconcile these two sort of
constructions these two frameworks and
we came up with some solutions in the
last lecture. Let me just remind you
where we stopped cuz the first solution
that we came up is that you can
discretise and then learn and this was
essentially a very very simple
procedure. So what you did is that or
what we did rather is that we started
out. So this is your example of a
solution operator. So we started out
with the input space for simplicity. I
took the input and the output space to
be the same function space. In general
this may not be the case but just for
simplicity. And then all that we did is
that we discretized. So this was a
sample sampling procedure sampling point
wise.
So we had the input and the output. We
put a grid on both. We took the samples.
So instead of looking at the whole
solution, we just had a finite
dimensional representation. N is a very
large vector. In my figure, it was 256
dimensional. In practice, this will be
much much larger dimensional. And then
the neural network comes in, it learns
this finite dimensional projection
essentially. And to go back to function
space, we can use interpolation. Right?
So I had this diagram that I showed you
how this is done. And this is how it
looked like. So you have uh an encoding
E which takes the infinite dimensional
uh data projects it down to finite
dimensional. You have a processor L
which is a neural network which
processes between finite dimensional
spaces. And finally you have a
reconstructor or a decoder which takes
you back to infinite dimensional spaces.
So this is a very very simple
construction essentially project learn
and then uh pull back right so that's
that's essentially the process but we
also figured out some problems okay so
this was the the detail here what you
learn is the projection right so you
project onto a finite dimensional space
and then you try to learn that but then
we also figured out that there are some
issues first of all very large model
sizes even for the simplest um one layer
network you can get up to 10 to 100
million which is what we want to avoid.
And then we also realize that the most
important thing is that we could not
evaluate on a different resolution right
because once we fix the set of points
this is fixed uh if you change the set
of points either by coarsening the
resolution or by making it finer we
could not even test. So this was not
genuine operator learning and this is a
word that I will come or a phrase that
will come by revisit again and again and
again. So this is this is an issue. So
what do we do in that case? uh we had uh
I think one of you even had suggested
this that there is a simple solution
which is a refinement of this sort of
discretization which is instead of using
a
MLP a plain vanilla multiron we could
use a CNN for instance there could be
some other alternatives but a CNN is is
good enough so what is a CNN if you
remember we did this in the second
lecture we also did it in one of the
tutorials a CNN is a very specific
specific spatial structure, right? So
remember that an MLP has this structure
A Z + B, right? So this is the structure
of an MLP whereas Z is a M crossM matrix
in general if Z is in RM, right? And
this whole matrix is learnable and this
is what essentially screwed up our
compute because we had very very large
dimensions here. So the idea behind a
CNN is that A is a sparse matrix
and it is essentially given by a
convolution kernel.
Convolution kernel. So this is the basic
idea. So what you do is that uh okay
notation is a little bit inconsistent. I
will try to correct that. But you see
that uh your input is given by some
now I'm a bit confused why yeah so your
input is given by some k for k is the
kernel here so this can also change k is
the kernel and then what happens is that
and if you want to see it pictorially we
just apply this kernel here too small in
the next slide I'm going to expand this
so then the weight matrix is going to be
very very sparse and this is a solution
that is at least scalable
Let me just explain it in some detail
right here. So remember that all that I
have to do is that the A now is not a
full dense matrix. It's a sparse matrix
because you multiply the same kernel in
every uh to the same spec to the patch
or the same spatial region and let's
look at it in a pictorial terms. Okay.
So this this guy here this tiny guy here
is a kernel, right? So what you do is
that you discretise. So this is your
input.
This is the input.
This the output.
And so you start with the input. You
your entire So these are different
channels. But just imagine that we have
a single channel. This is good enough to
understand what's going on. So you have
this tiny little kernel and you're going
to put this kernel and you're going to
sort of move the kernel window across
the entire domain. And you keep on doing
that. You have a different kernel and
then you have different kernel then you
have a different kernel and finally you
come to the output. So instead of
writing down some complicated formulas,
I think all of you should know by now
how to implement the CNN, it's very
clear that this is a much sparer
structure. So instead of having 100
million maybe with 100,000 the kernel
size of 100,000 several layers we can
manage quite well. So this is the first
thing that now what we can take is that
the model size is tractable. So instead
of having 100 million 10 the 8 we can go
down to I don't know 10 to the 4 10 to 5
no problem with that right so this is
much much more tractable. The second
thing is because our data has a very
specific spatial structure right spatial
structure is that these are points on a
grid. So as you can imagine the solution
of a PTE will respect that that if
neighboring points the solutions are
going to be close to each other. Of
course you could have discontinuities
that's always there but in general most
of the solution is going to be locally
connected points points which are close
to each other have very similar
solutions right so this is the huristic
and a CNN respects that because when you
when you multiply this kernel what you
do is that uh only the neighboring
points are taken into account and you
don't take very long distance uh
dependencies right so the structure is
very local in that sense we will we will
revert that later on but for the time
being that's good. So it respects the
spatial structure of the underlying
data. That's good. N MLP never did that,
right? In MLP, you take everything, put
it in a box and then get it out. Here
nearby points get multiplied with the
same kernel. Far off points are given
weight zero and then you keep on
processing. But the most important thing
is and remember that this for us was in
Latin synon an essential requirement for
operator learning. Now you can use any
any resolution, right? So if you
remember maybe I I actually try to
explain it a little bit more because
this is important. Let's take a new new
sheet of paper. So I did this example in
the last lecture. So remember that I
have an input output map.
So let's do this. So let's take some
function here and output maybe something
else. So this is your G the mapping
between these two and my just in one
dimension I can say that my mapping is
evaluated at these points 1 2 3 4 5 and
the output is also evaluated at 1 2 3 4
5. So with an MLP what you did is that
if you change the resolution you are
because you took a vector in R5 and then
you took an output in R5. But now what a
convolution does is very different and
it's very clever, right? So because what
we do is that we have this kernel uh now
I'm running out of color blue perhaps.
So we have a kernel K which I'm going to
pictorially represent with three points
for instance. Okay so K is just three
active members. So K1, K minus one, K0
and K1 for instance. And this is the
kernel that we're sliding over the
entire domain. Right? So instead of
multiplying a matrix, a full matrix with
this fivedimensional vector, what we're
doing is that we are iteratively
switching this kernel on and off. So for
instance, the first uh three points are
being hit by this kernel. Then the next
three points are again being hit by this
kernel. Now I'm running out of colors.
Let's use this hit by this kernel. The
last three points are being hit by this
kernel and so on. So this is the way in
which this iterative procedure works
right. So did you understand that that
is the same kernel that is being you can
ask me if you don't understand
something.
>> Yeah know I was thinking that CNN are
fixed in resolution. So now how
convolutions makes resolution
>> you'll see. So do you agree so far that
what I'm doing is exactly what a CNN
does that you take a kernel and you move
it across right so now what I want to
actually you did hit a very important
problem but remember our first uh this
is we have to do it in a step by step in
a gradualist manner right so the first
step is to see whether we can even
evaluate it in the next resolution so
far we haven't uh solved that problem
but it's a good problem what is the
fixed resolution and so on but you see
that we can move this and this is the
action of the CNN And the action of the
CNN is you take the kernel apply it to
three points take the same kernel apply
it to the next three points take the
next kernel apply it to three points and
so on and so forth and then you get some
rendition of the output okay so now
coming back to the first thing we want
to do is we change the resolution can we
even evaluate the CNN right so let's try
to do that let's uh let's go back draw
some pictures and I do it for the super
resolution in the case more points are
there and then we can also argue how it
is done with less points
Right. Let's take this. Okay. Now I
change the color of course.
Something like that. So this is your G,
right? And if you remember the points
that I took. Um, now of course I'm
losing out some colors here.
Yeah. Okay. So the points are perhaps
here.
1 2 3 4 5 and let's take some more
points right so we are super resolving
let's take the intermediate points this
one this one this one so now the
question is now my input and similarly
my output are given by these nine points
instead of the five points so now I take
the same kernel the kernel has been
trained right it's trained on whatever
resolution with five points but then I
can just apply it no problems right so
let's take the kernel and now let's
start with these three points I apply
the kernel I get an output next three
points I apply the same kernel I get an
output next three points I apply the
same kernel I get an output now it
becomes yeah so you see so I can keep on
sliding the kernel and the very least
I'm able to apply my CNN to a different
resolution which was not hither two
possible right because earlier it was
MLP it just took five points as input a
vector five dimensions as an input
produced a vector of five dimensional
input uh as an output. Now I can take a
ninth dimensional vector I can use my uh
threepoint kernel and I can produce an
output. Yes,
>> the optimal current for the first
resolution is probably not optimal for
the
>> you are absolutely right but again you
are preempting
the first problem that we are trying to
solve is a simple one right which is can
we even evaluate then we will come to
you you're absolutely both of you are
right that you're pointing out some
obvious problems with this method that
of course the kernels could change uh
why should the data if you think of it
it's uh not going to be that different
because there is some smoothness some
regular ity right so the three points
and five points are probably close to
each other but you'll see some some
effect of that in in a second but now
instead of having nine points I can if I
have 27 points I could do the same if I
have three points I could do the same
less than three I cannot apply because
then I have to use some padding and so
on but that's that's some specific thing
so now the basic structure that I'm able
to apply my neural operator or my neural
not neural operator neural network in in
a different setting or different
resolution is possible. Right? So this
is all that I wanted to illustrate. You
train on one resolution but then you are
only training a very local object that
you can apply to whatever. Right? So
this is the basic idea of using CNN's
which would have been impossible with
MLPS unless until you did some extra
extra step. Okay. So then at least the
the point that I'm trying to make and
this is a very important point is not
how accurate it is, how well it works
and so on that comes later but at least
it's possible to evaluate on any grad
resolution. So these are good things
right. So we have a structure we have
spatial structure that's incorporated we
have taken into account uh neighborhood
information we have a sparse matrix so
it's computationally efficient and we
can move it around and evaluate it on
resolution. The question is does it work
right? So this is this is the the
concerns that you guys just raised and
let's try to do some experiments to
understand what goes on and then the
theory follows almost automatically. So
the problem here is Navia Stokes well I
can write it down the equations again.
So what are Navia Stokes equations? So
if you remember this is u t plus u dot
grad u plus gradient of p is no llian of
u and divergence of u equals to zero. So
that's the equation. So you have a
velocity this is in 2D for simplicity.
You will see many 3D examples later on.
So it's 2D. So it's two components of
the velocity and the pressure is an
additional additional variables. So
there are three three uh unknowns and
three equations because the momentum
equations there are two and the
divergence constraints. So three
equations and three unknowns. The
solution operator the pressure is
somehow an implicit unknown. If I know
the velocity I know the pressure. So the
solution operator typically g takes my
initial conditions you not it's a vector
two vector and two vector function of
course and it produces a solution at any
given time. Okay. So this is the natural
uh solution operator here. For
simplicity, I take a cartisian domain uh
periodic boundary conditions. Make it as
easy as possible. Just focus on a simple
operator which takes the initial
conditions and produces the solution at
a later time. Okay. So this is going to
be the setup. Uh this is an example.
This is what is called a sheer flow. And
the vorticity omega is just a curl of
the velocity. In one dimension it's just
in two dimensions. This is just a scala
but three dimensions is a three vector.
So now if you look at what is happening
here. So we we are giving some shear. So
this is the velocity one direction of
the one component of the velocity field.
And as you as the flow evolves at time t
equal to one this is how the solution
looks like very non-intuitive but if you
look in terms of vorticity you take the
velocities you compute the vorticity
it's just a curl. Then you see what
happens. So in the beginning I have this
sort of sheer layers. These are very
common in for instance in atmospheric
flows that you have this shear layer and
then you apply a shear. Shear is
velocity in one direction and the
reverse velocity in the other direction.
Right? So you shear it. So once you
vortices are shared and this is how the
vorticity looks like. It's not the
easiest problem but it's not the hardest
problem either. So with my spectral
viscosity code it takes about 1/10enth
of a second. It's very very fast because
it's on a cartitionian grid. So now I do
what what we want to do which is that
you discretize it at a certain
resolution and we chose the resolution
64 squared.
We chose the resolution 64 squared. Now
don't ask me the details of the CNN that
was used. The CNN is of course not a 3x3
CNN. It's probably more expressive and
it has many many layers. Right? So it
also changes the channel dimension. But
a CNN was used and then we used
interpolation. Right? So you start you
take a uniform 64 squared grid apply the
CNN learn something on a 64 squared grid
the solution at a later time and then to
uh find out the solution at any any
other point you just use interpolation.
So this is the basic basic idea actually
it didn't do so badly. So at the
training resolution which is 64 squared
when you tested it what did we find that
the error was around 5%. This could have
been improved. 5% is not an absolute
number. It could be improved but let's
say 5% and we're satisfied with 5%. But
then the problem is uh so this is very
satisfactory right 5% to learn a fairly
complicated flow the inference takes
about a millisecond so one is happy
however there is a little caveat and I
think two of you have raised this caveat
that what really happens remember that
one of the things that we're aiming for
is to move towards different
resolutions. What does that mean? That I
train on a fixed resolution. This is my
training resolution. But I want to see
whether it generalizes, whether it has
actually learned the operator. So what
is the operator? It's a mapping which
takes a function into another function.
It is not a mapping which takes a 64
squar 4,96dimensional
vector and brings it to a
4,96dimensional vector, right? It's
really a mapping between functions and
functions. So in principle I can change
my resolution at any time in particular
test time. So instead of having 64
squared points I can take 32 squared
points or 96 squared points 128 squared
points I know what the solution is in
those points or in that resolution and
then we can test remember that now we
can evaluate the CNN. the CNN is trained
no it's it's I don't know a 5x5 kernel
matrix perhaps and then you slide it
through the entire 32x 32 or 128x 128
you can do it you can evaluate the
problem is as soon as you change the
training resolution
uh happens right because what
happens is that for instance here the
errors go up the errors go up similarly
here the errors go up so on both
directions when you increase the great
resolution some people call it a super
resolution and when you reduce the great
resolution some people call it a
subresolution in both the regimes as
soon as you do this um you don't get the
same level of error the error
immediately increases or some would
argue even exponentially increases right
so just by changing from 64 squared to
128 squared my error went from 5% to 25%
and similarly to go to 22 uh no not 22
32 squared it went up to 25%. So
actually you have you're not able to
generalize at all and in some sense
machine learning is all about
generalization. It's not just learning
the training data but is able to
understand something about what is being
learned. And here what you should have
understood is that it doesn't really
matter if I take something at 32 squared
or 64 squared they're representing the
same thing. So the error should be very
small between them. So if you just
interpolate or extrapolate this will be
a very very small number right but when
you do it using a CNN error just
explodes and so this shows that all the
factors which you guys said that maybe
the kernel is not optimal maybe the
fixed resolution is what kills us all of
them are going to be pertinent here and
indeed they are. So this is not my
finding or anything. This has been known
for quite a while. At least it is
documented by Nick Saharas uh from not
today quite a quite a quite a while back
in 2019. And the idea is that it is not
learning the operator right because all
that it is learning is a discrete
representation. It's learning the map
between a 64 squared vector to another
64 squared vector. This is going well,
right? 5% is not nothing to laugh at and
I know how to reduce it right this is
this is not an issue but the issue is
that it's not generalizing right so
essentially we could summarize this by
saying no generalization across
resolutions
why it happens we will find out right
but some speculations have already been
made right
and this is what we need we need this
generalization across resolutions to say
that it has understood or it has learned
something about the operator and not
just fit the training data. So this is
sort of the key point that I wanted to
make at this stage. Are there any
questions from the room here or also
from Zoom? If you have any questions
about this is a very very important
point. This ability to generalize
seamlessly across resolutions is what we
really are looking for and we'll spend a
couple of lectures on trying to explore
how to do that. So is this clear why
this is essential
and if not please feel free to ask
questions and then maybe no everything
is okay. Yes go ahead.
>> Do you have any insight on how would the
error look if we
redisretize to the grid resolution? So
you see for 128 we discretize that to a
64 bit byation and then
back to 128.
>> So you start with 128 you just down
sample to 64.
>> Yeah.
>> Then you train at 64.
>> Yeah. It's already
>> and then you test on the 64 itself or I
didn't understand.
>> No. So we have
>> okay okay okay now now now now now now
now now now now now now now now now now
now now now now now now now I get got
your points
>> of 128
>> and we want an output of 128 but what if
then we decrease the resolution to 64
>> and then after passing it we interpolate
back to 128
>> that's that's a very that's a very very
smart question it will be much better
>> it'll be much better because now we are
sort of project and you'll see why there
is a there's a mathematical there is a
proper scientific explanation of why
this happens. But uh it's a good
question. You'll you'll see in the next
lecture it will be clear why this
happens. Yes.
>> Is this going down? I mean this making
the resolution like smaller so the f CN
is also goes for the other methods as
well, right? Like is it like you said
>> with MLB you mean?
>> Yes. For example,
>> you could you could always do that but
uh then when you increase the resolution
you are in trouble, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So so it's only one way that you can do
it.
>> But but it would be it would still
improve the results.
>> It would it's possible to evaluate. It's
possible to evaluate but you still don't
solve the problem of having but coming
back to your question that that's okay
with 128 but what do you do with 32
then? you have to somehow increase the
resolution, right? It's so it's sort of
it's possible. What you're saying is not
impossible. You can take 32 and
interpolate to 64, apply your CNN at 64
and then uh down sample. This is this is
possible. You'll see that those
considerations will come in in a in a in
a minute. But that's a good good point.
Okay. So, let's move and see. So, this
doesn't work as it is. It does not
really generalize across resolutions. So
what can we do means um now I'm not able
to of course I'm sort of clicking there
there's a solution uh which is which is
possible so remember that what we did
now is that we took an infinite
dimension problem discretized projected
it down to finite dimensions worked in a
finite dimensional setting and then went
back right what do we do the other way
around which is that instead of uh
making our problem finite dimensional we
make neural networks infinite
dimensional Right. So this is this the
alternative that instead of uh
discretizing we first learn we make our
neural networks infinite dimensional and
then we discretize and these um
framework these this has a name these
are called neural operators
and the name itself was introduced by
Nick Kovachki and his co-authors not
that long back about four years back
and the idea is basically what I said we
all remember that uh if you Take a deep
neural network. You have all these
layers and each layer has a very
specific set of operations, right? So
this Y is finite dimensional. So Y your
input is in RM, right? And you multiply
with a M by a matrix. This matrix could
have some special structure like in a
CNN or it not have some special
structure but like in an MLP and then
you add a bias vector another M
dimensional vector and then you apply a
pointwise nonlinearity component wise
nonlinearity. So at each component you
use a relu or a hyperbolic tangent or
whatever. So the idea that Nick and his
co-authors had was can we sort of
generalize this to infinite dimensions.
So this is a very finite dimension
construction takes in a vector churns
out a vector at the other end. So an
infinite dimensional extension of this
would be an analog of this would be to
take in a function as input and churn
out a function as output. Right? And
this is what neural networks do. So
they're essentially a generalization of
neuronet networks to infinite
dimensions. So now the basic structure
is the same. It's compositional right.
So you just compose uh different uh
things. You compose different layers.
But each layer now is no longer a
mapping between um final dimensional
spaces. It's a mapping between infinite
dimensional spaces. And all that I did
is that I put the input and output space
the same. It need not be the same. Okay.
Just for simplicity, notational
simplicity, understanding input and
output space are the same. But of
course, now we need to extend, right? So
we need to change a few things. So my
input now
instead of a y, my input is a function.
So my bias vector cannot be a vector
anymore because I can't take a function
and a vector. So I have to do something
about that. The key is I have to change
the weight matrix. Right? The matrix
matrix is a finite dimensional object. I
have to extend it to infinite dimensions
and similarly with the activation
function I have to do something because
I use the activation function pointwise.
So all these three things have to be
changed for me to be able to understand
and uh not understand but extend what's
going on. So is that clear? So we need
to change the bias vector, we need to
change the weight matrix and we need to
change the activation function. And
there are some canonical choices that we
can make and these canonical choices
lead to what is called a neural
operator. The first canonical choice
that we make is that instead of having
remember that my input was something
like this a y + b a k y okay let's take
k the kth layer ak y + bk and instead of
this bk which is a vector remember that
my input now input to the kth layer is v
so v is a function of space right so it
is evaluable at points in space it's a
function So instead of having a vector I
just changed the bias to some sort of a
function and functions can be learned
right means whole function can be
learned it can be represented in terms
of basis whose components can be learned
and so on. We have to specify that. So
instead of having a vector I have a
function here means I can evaluate it at
every point an obvious extension. The
harder extension is of course this
matrix vector multiply and the matrix
vector multiply is the essence of neural
networks that you multiply matrix
learnable matrix with a vector but now
we have to think of an infinite
dimensional extension of the matrix
vector multiply and this is provided
anyone who has done basic math or signal
processing electrical engineering knows
this that when you go from discrete
vectors to continuous functions matrix
vector multiply becomes or can be
replaced by what is called a kernel
integral operator and this is sort of
the key key operation. So actually I did
use L here. So let me correct to L. So
instead of L A L of Y I take a kernel
function. A kernel function is a
function that can be evaluated at uh two
two components or two points X and Y
instead of just uh X itself. I take this
kernel function. I throw it against the
input function and then I integrate over
the domain. All right. So all of you
will agree with me that this is a very
canonical uh extension or a canonical
lift of a finite dimensional matrix
vector multiply operation because when
you discretize this you take the reman
sum this is the summation of KL at Xi YJ
V of YJ sum over J. So that's your only
man sum right and if you write this as a
kernel as vectors this is nothing but KL
some matrix time V right so this is a
very very simple extension it's not the
only possible extension but it's it's a
canonical one so this was their proposal
that instead of having uh local matrix
vector multipliers you make it non-local
you take the structure of space into
account and then you end up with these
kind of kernel integral operators and
the last point was the activation itself
So the activation now is a function
right. So all that you do is they they
suggested we will we'll see that that
doesn't work in general that your sigma
is still your loop but you apply it
pointwise. What do I mean? So sigma of a
function f evaluated at a point x is
simply sigma applied to the f ofx. Okay.
So you take all the evaluation points
because remember that this guy is a
function. No problem. It can be
evaluated at any point. This guy is a
function. No problem. It can also be
evaluated at any point. So now you if
you think of both of them, it's some f a
function which is evaluable at any point
and then we apply a sigma
and you get uh the point wise
evaluation. So this was the proposal
that you replace a bias vector with a
bias function. You replace uh matrix
vector multiply with a kernel integral
operator and you replace uh and you keep
the pointwise evaluation as component
wise evaluation as it is but you apply
pointwise right and these kind of
operators have a name they're called
neitski operators but uh that's that's
that's a detail right so where is the
learning happening where where do the
learning parameters sit so these are in
this BL in the bias function and in the
kernel function. We still have to learn
the kernel in some sense, right? But
it's a continuous everything is now in
function space. Everything is in terms
of functions. So you have to learn
functions. So is this construction
clear? It's really canonical. You take
finite dimensional objects. Look at the
closest thing that they can be lifted to
in infinite dimensions. Lift them. Okay.
And this is a very minimalist uh kind of
a kind of a extension or construction.
But of course um in in in practice we we
we cannot really work with this right
because we we cannot compute in infinite
dimensions right because we for for
starters we cannot compute an integral
we don't know how to do it by hand
except in the simplest possible cases.
So it's not like we have a solution
formula we have a we have a closed form
expression for this very complex
expression. And remember that these are
several layers. So you have layer after
layer after layer. So there's no way on
earth that we can evaluate these things.
So at the end of the day you can write
what you want mathematically in infinite
dimensions just one sec. But uh in
practice to implement something on
computer you have to come back to finite
dimensions in some form or the other.
Right? So that's why there is a
learning. So this is a learning process
which can be written by hand but there's
a discretization process. Hence learn
and discretise. This is sort of the
basic objective. Yes. Go ahead.
>> It's not necessarily linear.
necessarily be linear mean it's enough
that it is linear. You'll see examples
where it is linear and then we change it
to something which is going to be
nonlinear. The reason why we keep it
activation function is it could be
identity. So no no no one stops us
mathematically from doing the identity
is when you see later on not not in
today's lecture not in the next lecture
but the lecture after that probably we
are going to look at nonlinear kernels
and you will see that transformers
attention the main sort of backbone of
transformers is a nonlinear kernel but
then you need a you need a relu or some
pointwise nonlinearity just to ensure
universal approximation because without
that it is not possible. So you still
will need it even for very complex
operators. But it's a good question.
Think of it if everything is nonlinear
then identity, right? So that's always
possible. Further questions? No. So what
is the what's the issue then? The issue
is that we have to discretise, right?
And when we discretise then things
become not so easy. Why is that? So
remember that my action is given. So we
need to discretize. We cannot simply
write down the formula. So we have the
integral of k of xy even if this is a
linear object dy plus b of x something
like this. So this is my formula and
this is I don't know n l of v at the
point x right. So this is the formula.
So now if I do it naively what happens
and there are choices right? So what are
the choices? The choices are what is K,
what is B, what is sigma. All these
choices need to be made. And what I also
need to make is how to discretise.
Right? The naive way is that you put a
set of points a bunch of points and you
discretise it. So so instead of having X
you you choose for all Xi belong to D,
you have NL of V applied to X I equals
to sigma. And now we use this u demon
sum essentially
or a Monte Carlo sampling if you want
summation of a j of k of x i y j v of yj
plus b of xj something like that and we
we will parameterize k in some finite
dimensional ways but you immediately see
that for each point I have to do this
sum over all the end points right in the
domain and Then if I have n points for
each of them if I have n points so my
complexity scales like order of n
squared
n is the number of uh sampling points.
We also have to check for u different
resolutions and so on. And this can be
very expensive computationally because
just imagine if you have 4,96 points
this is already 4,96 squared operations
per layer right? And then if you have
five layers you have 100 million uh
computations which is very very
expensive. So there there are choices
and these choices have to be guided
towards reducing the computation
complexity. We cannot we cannot naively
do this because unlike in sort of basic
applications of neural networks here we
have the inputs are going to be a very
dense computationally intense object. So
for instance, routinely these days we
have uh up to a billion input points
right. So if you have a very complex uh
aircraft and you want to discretise it
into fine pieces you will end up with a
billion input points. Then this becomes
one has to be very very careful. So we
have to be guided by how to reduce the
computational complexity and how do we
make these choices. There are many many
different examples and we will go
through a few in the course and after
the break we will take up at least one
particular choice which is quite
effective FIA neural operator and then
we'll see how these choices are going to
be made. So now let's uh take a break.
Let's say that we meet at 10-minut break
and then we we resume to see some
concrete examples
and okay so what is uh so remember that
we have to make some good choices so
that this computational complexity which
ended up being quadratic and the number
of points can be reduced remember that I
said that we can easily have 10 million
100 million points and then the square
of that is just a very very large number
we cannot afford that we have to be
smart. So one smart choice which is
probably the most popular in some sense
and is always a baseline uh even today
was proposed in 2020. It's called the
FIA neural operator
because everything happens in to some
extent in FIA space and is proposed by
the same group of authors that came up
with the idea of neural operators but
this time it was different. first author
Joy Lee who is currently at MIT but he
was at Caltech at that time and their
observation was a very smart one that in
general your kernel need not be random
kernels right we have to parameterize
the kernel somehow and in physics one of
the most important things that happens
is translation invariance things are not
dependent on where you sit the same
physical laws apply if you change your
frame of reference if you if you move
position and so on and so forth so if
you want to make it translation
invariant then what happens is that this
uh relationship XY is simply in the
translate X minus Y right so this is a
very very common answer that we can put
it C andn's convolutions have exactly
the same answer that things are
translation invariant so once they're
translation invariant what happens to
this kernel integral operator the kernel
integral operator becomes a convolution
right so you have a function which is k
is k of x - y multiplied with v of y.
This becomes a convolution. You can
shift the x - y to the other side. So
it's it becomes a convolution. You could
have just stuck to a convolution with
either a sort of a sparse kernel or even
a dense kernel. But they said no no
let's do this convolution in fiery
space. Okay, we will come back to
convolution in physical space in the
next lecture. But we can do convolution
in FIA space. So how do you do
convolution in FIA space means uh first
of all just for notational purposes all
of you should know what what goes on. So
just for notational purposes I have uh
written down the FIA transform which is
a mapping which takes any L2 function
any square integraable function and then
it evaluates this. So this is just a
component of the function. It's a in
general it can be complex valued but we
typically take real valued functions. So
the complex uh component is zero the
imaginary part is zero but in general
you can take component complex valued
functions and then you given given a
function you sort of uh take out its
frequency content right so that's what
happens so the j component at the kth
frequency is given by multiplying or uh
multiplying and integrating across a
fier kernel right so this is sort of the
it goes back to fier back in the day and
this is what a fiery transform does so
You take a function and you extract its
frequency information. So this is for
you transform and the inverse of it you
given a bunch of frequencies function is
represented in frequency or phase space
and you come back to physical space by
essentially summing over FIA kernels
inverse FIA kernels. So this is FIA
transform and inverse FIA transform. You
take a function in physical space
transform it to frequency space and with
the inver inverse FIA transform you
bring it back. Right? So this is the
basic idea and the reason why they did
it and I'll give you a little and I know
that there has already been a tutorial
on this is that uh convolution so what
happens to convolution in FIA space it
becomes a multiplication right so convol
this is basic uh math basic signal
processing a convolution becomes a
multiplication so instead of having a
convolution here so you can imagine that
uh you take the FIA transform you take
the kernel multiplier I I'll in the next
slide I'll give you a little bit more
details about this and then you take a
inverse for transform. So essentially
the idea is that instead of having a
kernel which is sitting in physical
space making it very complex
computationally you parameterize the
kernel in FIA space and this is the
basic idea and the key point is that the
number of FIA modes that you can take
are fixed. So it's fixed number of FIA
modes. This is an important detail as
you'll see and the whole sort of rise on
the tray of this the rationale behind
this choice is the fact that you can do
fy transforms very efficiently at least
on a grid by using the fast fy transform
right the fast transform is this
ultimate algorithm that you all learn in
your basic numerical analysis or
algorithms class and if you are on a
grid instead of uh fa transform so this
integral here which would have been
order of n squ So what happens when we
do a FIA transform of a function with n
points? Uh you compute the same integral
but what is the computational complexity
now? Who will tell me? So it is uh so if
you have n input points uh what the FFT
does is that it does the FIA transform
with what complexity? Who can tell me n
login right? So this is the key key
point behind the 4 year transform versus
order of n² and remember that if n is a
large number let's say even if it is
10,000 right so 10,000 n squar is uh 100
million that's a very very large number
but n log n is
100,000 right so it's a much much
smaller number so this was sort of the
key point and here is a sort of
pictorial representation and I will do a
little bit more detail in a second. So
what you do here is that so this is just
a kernel rule. So there is no bias. You
can add a bias but it's not not
essential in this is that so you have a
function a which is your input and your
output is given by u. So this is your uh
fno the whole thing is called the fno.
So it starts off by doing what is called
a projection or a p a lifting if you can
you can call it as a lifting. So this is
essentially adding more features. uh
again I will explain that so this is
just a linear in general a linear object
and then so instead of having let's say
that we're starting with the velocity of
a fluid these are just two components so
it takes this at every point and says
that okay instead of two components it
could be eight components or 16
components well let's say the vorticity
stream function blah blah blah and this
is learnable right and then you go
through each of these fial layers uh
depending on the architecture depending
on the capacity depending on what you
can do your compute you can have 10 f
layers for instance five f layers and
then you have a sort of a reduction or
so this is a projection back in some
sense so instead of having 16 components
you come back to the two components of
the velocity and this is going to be
output so this is it can be written
entirely in terms of functions and the
way we do it is that you take a function
right in the fia layer you take a fa
transform of it this can be
You multiply this matrix which is in FIA
space. Now again in the next slide I'll
write down the details of it. And then
you take a inverse FIA transform. So you
pull it back to physical space. One can
always add this kind of a residual
connection. This is uh this is not an
issue. It can also be zero. Okay. And
then uh so you add these two. So if this
is zero, you don't have to add. And then
you apply this pointwise.
Okay. So the convolution is performed in
FIA space. The activation is performed
in physical space. The convolution is
essentially a non-local. It's a global
object, right? Because it's done in 4
years space. The activation on the other
hand is a local object. It is done at
every point. Okay? So this is sort of
the key behind it and let me just
because this is so important FNO let me
just explain it a little bit more. I
know that in the tutorial Bokdan or
whoever Shien they probably did this but
uh let me just uh explain it a little
bit and just for simplicity so that we
are not killing ourselves with notation
I'll stick to just uh one space
dimension so that it's it's fairly
simple so you have a function remember
that you have to discretise everything
and then we have to also see when we
change the resolution how we can uh
apply the operator right so you have
some domain Here you have a set of
points.
Let us say that I have n points, right?
And my input is a vector
uh let's say v v which is at each of
these n points. Okay. And let's say that
it's a scalar. So for each j for all j
vj which is equal to v of xj is a
scalar. This for instance could be the
concentration uh in some problem. So
then what are the different operations
that we have in an FN O. First is this
lifting operator P. So this is
essentially learning effective
coordinates. So when I apply P I apply
it to each the same P to each of these
points. So P is a matrix let's say
and this could be in general M cross it
could be just a vector M cross one
matrix or M vector and then it's applied
to each of these points P of V of XJ or
P of VJ this is equal to WJ so P is not
dependent on J it's independent of J. So
this is in machine learning this is
called channel mixing. So instead of
just having RGB, you somehow mix the
channels by introducing new channels.
From a physical perspective, you can
think of this as learning some effective
coordinates where the system can be
better expressed. Okay, so this is a
very straightforward operation. It does
not depend on the number of points
because you're applying the same thing
to every every single point. Okay, but
what it does is that this WJ now is in
RM, right? So it's a M dimensional
vector. All this can be done very
efficiently in code. I'm just making it
as simple as I can in class. Now we go
to the FIA layer. Just one FIA layer is
good enough
because otherwise it's just a
composition. So my input now is this WJ
one less than J less than N and each WJ
is an RM. Right? So this is I keep on
repeating that this is a M vector. And
now what I can do is that I can take the
discrete because uh it's a FIA transform
but it's actually the discrete FIA
transform. I don't have to write the
definition. What the discrete FIA
transform does is that it takes all
these points right the function at all
these points and it transforms it into a
fixed set of frequencies. So let's say
that uh the fixed set of frequencies are
given by W hat little K. Okay. So this
is a discrete FIA transform. How do I
write this? I didn't write it properly
and ask me questions because this is
important, right? So in case something's
unclear. So what do I have? I take DFT.
So this is my WJ. Each of them is this M
vector, right? J from 1 to capital N.
And this is transformed to W hat of K.
And now my little K is between some big
capital K less than K less than capital
K. Right? So we need both positive and
negative frequencies and we have this
and each of these WK is in RM just for
simplicity. Well, it is in RM. It's just
a FIA transform. So it has to be in RM.
Right? So this is what we do. We take a
FIA transform. We transform this uh
input function into a set of fixed
frequencies. In general, in general 2k +
1 is these are the number of frequencies
is going to be much less than n. in
general it need not be but in general
let me now try to
okay what's going on
so this is much less than it so the
number of points could be I don't know
10,000 but the number of frequencies
could be 30 or 60 uh if you add the 61
so this is uh what it does and it does
it using FFT so DFFT so this is a very
very fast algorithm it does not scale
with the number number of input points
it really quadratically but log
linearly. Okay, is this clear? So you
take a vector or a set of vectors and
you transform them into a set of
frequencies each of which is a vector.
So now comes this learnable matrix. So
this is your FIA multiplier.
FIA multiplier
and here you can mix things up. Okay.
Now so far nothing has been mixed. These
are just uh dft is just a fixed
operation but this matrix now so now if
you if you couple all these vectors so
you can take r
could be in general it's a tensor but in
multi-dimensions it has to be a tensor
but in 1D I can write it as a matrix so
this is a 2k + 1 * matrix right so this
is a matrix so now what the fa
multiplier does is that when you
multiply it with
uh W hat.
So W hat was simply W K
for all K. K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K
K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K
K K K K K K from minus capital K to
capital K. So all the frequencies now
you can mix them together and this is
what is done by this matrix and higher
dimensions you can imagine that this
will be a tensor depending on what kind
of dimensions you have. So now you have
the FIA multiplication. So this is
learnable. So this is learnable.
Okay. Why? What happened here? Right? So
this is learnable
and it has a dimension which is
independent of the number of points.
This is very very important. It depends
on the number of frequencies to which
you're projecting and the number of
feature vectors that you have. Right? So
it's independent of the number of
points. Now the pointwise information is
completely gone and it is put into
frequency space. Then you do the inverse
for year transform discrete inverse for
year transform. So this would be a d if
or IDF depending on how people call it.
So you take this to be w tilda perhaps.
So now w tilda is this frequencies
right? So you have these frequencies and
now you go back to your physical space.
So you call it as uj. So let's let's see
how to write this. This is not the right
way to write it. So what it takes is
that it takes this w tilda
each of them is a vector now right it's
a m vector but they are k from minus
capital k to capital k and you transform
this because it's a inverse for your
transform so you transform this to w no
u I said u was the notation
I should have written this but I thought
that if I do it slowly in class you'll
understand better right? But of course
then I'll make a mistake. So this is W.
It's
U perhaps J
and for some reason my pen is
misbehaving 1 to N and each U.J is now
in RM. Right? So nothing is learnable
here means this is just FFT and D
inverse FFT are not learnable objects.
This is just you press a button and you
get uh so what did we do now? So we took
some input uh we took its frequency
content we mixed them together with this
matrix and with the inverse FFT we got
another uh n dimensional vector at each
space point right so this uh dft and d
if are not learnable at all and then the
last point is of course your activation
I could have multiplied this residual
but this the residual connection or skip
connection but that's not important now
this is simply sigma
of u.j
one less than j le less than n. Okay, so
this is how it proceeds. It's a it's a
pretty straightforward algorithm and if
you look at the code that bogdan and
shashang introduced it's fairly
straightforward to implement. Now there
are several remarks that I want to make
but are are there any questions about
this? Yes, go ahead.
Yes,
>> then it wouldn't be. But that's the key
trick and you'll see why there is uh
this is the whole point is that you cut
the frequencies. If you did not cut the
frequencies you kept uh in fact the way
they write it in their paper it's as if
you can take every frequencies but then
they put zero they they multiply a dense
matrix but they put zeros for the high
frequencies. So I take that fluff out
and I simply say that you cut the
frequencies. Okay. And uh this is the
key point because otherwise we would not
have if the number of frequencies was
relying on the grid resolution then
you're out of business. Right? So the
only so there are two things here. First
is that I can apply it to any mesh
resolution. Now why? Because it does not
depend on the number of points. All that
the input function of course depends on
the number of points but the learnable
objects these are the and then the Q the
Q is just the opposite of so this Q is
just the opposite
the inverse of P right so these are not
uh these are these are just pointwise
operations right so this P is
independent of the number of points uh
DFT and DIT are not learned anyway R is
independent of the number of points this
just depends on the frequency
And then sigma is also independent of
the number of points. It's applied to
every point anyway. So now you can
seamlessly apply it to different uh
resolutions whatsoever. Is that clear?
It's uh the whole construction is made
in such a manner that you are allowed to
by cutting off the frequencies. There's
a price that you pay because of that as
you'll see. But uh because of that you
are allowed to evaluate at every
resolution. That doesn't mean that uh
you it generalizes across every
resolution but in principle you can
apply it. Okay. Yes. Go ahead.
>> How do you decide we cut frequencies?
Does it depend on the physics of the
problem?
>> It it's a hyperparameter.
>> Okay.
>> It's a hyperparameter. We did a lot of
extensive study of this and we have used
this architecture ourselves for I don't
know 5 years since it began. But uh what
I can tell you is that you never need
more than 30 frequencies mean we have
never seen any because it grows with the
number of frequencies right your
computational complexity grows with the
number of frequencies. So we have never
seen that more than 30 helps and there
is a reason for that you know even if
your function has 100 frequencies if
these are solutions of PDS the high
frequencies are generally damped right
it's uh so there is there is a reason
for that but it's it's a good question
it's a hyperparameter you choose it
depending on your computational budget
so there's the first point that you can
now do whatever you want across
resolutions it does not really matter
the second point is that there is
nothing which is uh preventing me from
saying that this P
uh R Q I I could have easily added a
bias vector here, right? I could have
just added a B. So some people have
added a bias. It's not important for my
purposes. Q this at the moment these are
just matrices, right? These are matrices
with fixed inputs and fixed outputs
which are independent of the number of
points. But in principle these could be
MLPS,
right? MLPS which take for instance this
would take 2k + one u you know m inputs
and produce 2k +1 outputs right you
could just take a mlp and do this
exactly the same thing so this could be
mps this is a generalization it doesn't
add a lot I know a few papers have been
written on this but it doesn't really
add a lot but this is sort of the
overall construction of an fno but the
best way to see it is to go back to your
tutorial look at the code which has been
provided and you see the different
elements how this how this kind of come
together how it is implemented in a
tensorial manner so that
multi-dimensions can be handled properly
so that's fo for you
if there are also questions on zoom I
would be happy to take it but no one has
asked anything so it turns out that very
quickly after so as I said fno is very
widely used in practice it's by far the
most common infinite dimensional
algorithm in um in in this context right
so it's widely used in practice in fact
more or less immediately after it was
proposed Nick Kovachki and myself and
Sam Lantaler because in the beginning
you would argue how does it matter with
this means you're doing everything in
fiery space uh are you able to
approximate arbitrary operators or not
and the answer was very quickly provided
uh that we showed that indeed as long as
you have a measurable operator
continuous think Remember that I had
this universal approximation theorems.
So if you have a continuous operator for
instance which maps some infinite
dimensional space to another infinite
dimensional space the details are not
important then the error that you make
to with this operator the error is
measured in this way. Now it's an error
over function space as well as over the
physical space right because you have to
integrate somehow this is small. So
essentially just like neural networks
are universal oper universal
approximators of functions neural
operators particularly fia neural
operator is a universal approximator of
operators okay so that is a complete
analogy in that sense so even though
you're doing all these things in FIA
space you you don't lose anything you
can still do it universally but remember
that it's very important to apply the
nonlinearity if you don't have the
nonlinearity you don't have universal
approximation. So this is as I said it's
very widely used in practice and so on.
But remember that our objective to
introduce the 4year level operator was
to see whether the problems that we had
with CNN's are solved or not. Right? So
the question was whether it seamlessly
generalizes across resolutions. Uh does
anyone have a question or no? Okay. So
does it seamlessly generalize across
resolutions? Right.
Let's see if it does. So let me take an
example. This is a extreme example uh
because we understood the mechanism by
which it doesn't, right? And the example
is between random functions essentially.
So operator, right? Anything is an
operator. So what you do is that you
take a random field. This is noise but
um operators operators. This is a
measurable operator. So it's not nothing
that you can do. So you essentially have
some noise. So random field
and you map the random field to another
random field
by essentially rearranging things at
random. So you take any point. No, I
can't. Yeah, you take a point here
and you take a point here and in the
next uh in this target this guy goes to
this point and this guy goes to the
other point something like this. So it's
a random assignment and this is not a
continuous operator but it's a
measurable operator. All the properties
are there but it's a nasty operator.
This is not a solution of a PD but it's
an operator nevertheless because you're
reassigning things randomly. It turns
out that the same problem that uh was
the bane of CNN's remains here. So what
do we do? So we have this uh okay forget
about this uh things equivalence and not
but essentially we trained it at 64
squared this particular operator. So at
64 squared whether I take fn or whether
I take CNN they learned it very very
quickly that I'm just shuffling points
randomly. So and they were able to learn
what is the order of this shuffling. No
problems with that. The moment I changed
the resolution even by one pixel in both
directions. So I went to 63 squared or
65 squared. Then all hell broke loose.
FNO also was not uh there exploded in
both directions. Here it learned
something which was bias. The same with
CNN. So there's no way that for general
operators mean if you are resolution
invariant then you are resolution
invariant for everything. But at least
for this operator we found that just by
changing one grid resolution uh by keep
because now remember that uh one of your
colleagues raised this right by keeping
the frequencies cut off is how we are
managing but now what we're doing with
this random assignment is that we are
fooling around with that we are adding
or we are not letting the frequencies
die out as a consequence you see that
there is there is no seamless
generalization but this is a example
that has been plucked on purpose is to
make it uh very difficult to generalize.
But if you go back to our standard
example, we we see exactly the same
phenomena but not as dramatically now.
Right? So what do we see? If you
remember the same same result before the
CNN did not generalize at all. What
about the FNO? So what happens here is
that if you train it actually the the
error is quite small. It's 3 and a half%
which is very very good. later on you'll
see that something is 0% but uh three
and a half uh something generalized as
well but now when I change the
resolution you see that it's in this
regime it seems that it does not uh it
has the same error right but it actually
there is a very slight increase in error
there is an increase right it sort of it
goes up like this but if you subresolve
if you reduce the mesh resolution then
it behaves much more dramatically so
almost immediately the error is
increased it's much less than in a CNN
and there is a mathematical reason for
it which we'll probably see in uh
tomorrow's lecture but uh no not
tomorrow's but next next week's lecture
but again the same same feature comes
out that uh the the high frequencies are
damped but they are very much there and
you don't have this seamless integration
so our objective of learning not just a
discrete representation but actually
learning the operator is still not
fulfilled by FNO even though FNO is a
very good choice and it sort of it
reduces this problem considerably
earlier it was like 25% in both
directions maybe it was this unit it's
not a CNN slightly different but uh
again it's not as dramatic as before
it's reduced but it's not gone okay so
this is sort of the the catch here that
it's an it's a very effective uh way
it's a sort of intuistic way of uh
learning operators But it doesn't learn
the operator at the end. Okay. And we
will understand the reason why it
doesn't do that. Are there any
questions? Yes. Go ahead.
>> So in the previous example it didn't
work where we
>> also here it didn't work. Both examples
it didn't work. Here
you know when you generalize it should
be flat right when but it worked much
better because high frequencies in a PTE
are damped. That's the whole point of a
PD is that it regularizes things quite a
bit.
>> So the worst example, the operator was
not local.
>> It was not local.
>> And in PD there should always be no no
PDS are not. Think of the personal
equation for instance, right? So what do
you do? Uh you take the personal
equation uh and you take a right hand
side and then the solution of the PTE is
given by integrating with respect to the
greens function. Right? So this is the
green's function is a non-local
operator. Only thing is that it decays
far out but it's non-local but it decays
far out and that's why the in frequency
when you map it into frequency it simply
tells you that the high frequencies have
less contribution to the solution than
the low frequencies. In this particular
case nothing like that happens. So high
frequencies can have the same
contribution as the low frequencies.
There's no mechanism to hide this uh
cutting off frequencies you know. So
that's why things are attenuated.
So it's done on purpose to sort of
elicit this kind of a behavior. But you
can just uh this was just a dramatic
example of things not working. But even
here things didn't work um in a seamless
manner even though it was much better.
Further questions? Yes. Yeah. First
frequency space. What is the reason for
that?
>> Uh why do we have negative frequencies?
>> No. Why do we use convolutions in the
frequency?
>> We don't use convolution in the
frequency space. The convolution in
physical space becomes a multiplication
in frequency space.
Right? Well, when when you take a FIA
transform of a convolution, you get so
in other words, you take uh you take the
FIA transform, right? Cap hat is nothing
but k hat * v hat, right? So, this is
what happened. So, remember that we we
sort of implemented realize the
convolution in physical space through a
multiplication in 4 year space. But now
you cannot guarantee that your kernel is
going to be locally supported. It's
going to be a global object. You had a
question. You had a question. Yes.
>> The same way that on the example you
mentioned that if we need some to bring
the uh training resolution error down,
would that be possible for the or is it
>> uh it's possible. It's not as uh it's
not as clean as with the CNN example.
It's possible. You'll see in the next
lecture why this will it's possible but
it can bring down the error but it will
not reduce it to zero.
And I would guess that as we have some
ext
loaded word means let's not use
superiority in in any any way but these
are all viable options. We should
understand what are the advantages and
disadvantages of a particular particular
example. Right? So now we really want to
learn the operator not just a discrete
representation primarily not because
it's some aesthetically pleasing to a
mathematician like me it is
aesthetically pleasing but in general we
want to generalize this is this the main
point about machine learning is it
should not learn the training data it
should learn something more than the
training data so that it can generalize
right so it's challenging to learn an
operator and why is that remember that
in principle you have a mapping from
functions to functions Uh so this is a
this is a mapping in practice you have
to work with discrete settings right and
discrete settings could be grades it
could be very very complicated sort of
sensors which are distributed randomly
more or less points point clouds and
there this change right so this can
really change between resolutions so
what it means is that the same
continuous object can have multiple
discrete resolutions you can change the
resolution you can change the location
of the sample points you can do various
funky things with it. You have multiple
discrete resolutions, right? And we are
condemned to use discretization because
on our current digital computers, maybe
someday analog computers, quantum
computers, light based optical
computing, neuromorphic computing, these
things will become reality. But as we
speak, uh it's just this digital machine
that that works. So we have to
discretize. We have to work with
discrete objects. We cannot work with
continuous objects. Right? So what we
need to understand is some link between
the container the infinite dimensional
world and the discrete which is more of
a finite dimensional world and there
should be some tight coupling some some
understanding between that. So what we
need is some equivalence between them
because if there was an equivalence then
we'll learn the operator not a
particular discrete representation of it
and just call it I call it as a
continuous discrete equivalence and
let's try to understand what that is a
little bit today and maybe in the next
uh lecture we can we can develop more
about that. So remember that my operator
G is my general generic uh notation for
an operator. It takes an infinite
dimensional object uh into an infinite
dimensional object function into
function. Right? Now in I'm condemned as
I said to work with discrete objects. So
discrete objects are not given by this
calligraphic G calligraphic G but by
capital G here and these are finite
dimensional spaces vector spaces. So
this is sort of the and I have to go
between the two right. So this is the
essential link and so you have to this
is what we have been trying to do. We
have either trying to pull it down to
some discrete uh object then apply some
discrete version of G and go go back or
we take this here push it to a infinite
dimensional space learn and come back.
So essentially the trick is to find out
how we move between infinite dimensions
and finite dimensions. And this is this
can be challenging. And what is
interesting is that uh the way we can do
this this was realized uh by us again
some some years ago in this paper is
that these two processes that I told you
discretise and learn or learn and
discretize these two processes have to
commute. These two have to agree to the
same uh to the same point in order to
make it uh genuine operator learning. So
let me explain a little bit means this
is it can become a bit theoretical but
it's in some sense intuitive. So
remember that um these uh question marks
that I had I replace them with some
encoding and some reconstruction
operators. So encoding essentially takes
an infinite dimensional object pulls it
back to finite dimensions.
Reconstruction goes from finite
dimensions to infinite dimensions.
Right? So what you what you can do is
that your operator is a mapping here. So
it goes infinite to infinite or what you
can do is you can pull it down to finite
dimensions. Apply a discrete version of
the operator and push it back. Right?
And what you need is that these two
things should be the same. Right?
Because if these two things are not the
same then there are problems. So this is
what we want. This is our aim. The
question, it's a question.
Are we there or not? And in fact, we
realize that we are only there when the
so-called aliasing error, this comes
from signal processing. Those who have
done electrical engineering would know
this uh aliasing error which is
precisely the mismatch between the two.
So we are saying that there is a
continuous object and we are saying that
we realize the continuous object by
taking it pushing it down to finite
dimensions learning its counterpart in
finite dimensions pulling it up. These
two things have to be exactly the same.
When they are the same there is no
aliasing error and if they're not the
same this is just a terminology it's
called aliasing error. Okay. And what we
required is that your neural operator or
your operator learning framework does
not have this elasing errors. So if what
you write down on paper is exactly what
you implement on a computer or in
practice maybe it's a small small
quantity. So this is the basic idea
behind what is called a reeno or a
representation equivalent neural
operator. So remember that the same
continuous object has multiple discrete
representations. Our idea was that
whatever be the discrete representation
that you have, it should be exactly the
same. It's just a continuous object.
These are different ways of looking at
continuous objects. So that's why we
called it as a representation equivalent
neural operator. And of course uh we
demanded that this be exact. It could be
approximate but we demanded that this be
exact. And this is done in a layer-wise
manner because we know that neural
networks people stack things on top of
each other. So for each layer my
aliasing error is going to be zero right
and when it is zero for every layer the
composition is going to be zero and you
get what is called a venu or a
representation equivalent dual operator.
So this for us is the ultimate form of
discrete continuous equivalence plus
whatever happens in discrete finite
dimensions is replicated in the
continuous or infinite dimensions. So
this is a requirement. We don't have an
example yet but this is a requirement
that we it's a very valid requirement if
you think of it whatever happens in
finite and whatever happens in infinite
they can be mapped onto each other right
very very reasonable requirement and an
immediate consequence of that is that
then you can push between different
discrete because this is what we did
right we never have a continuous
representation but what we did is that
we worked with multiple discrete
representations multiple mesh sizes mesh
resolutions for instance
So what Reno does is that it seamlessly
provides a way to go between two
different resolutions, right? So for
instance, this is your G. Think of this
X and Y as uh X and X and X prime as two
different mesh resolutions for instance.
Right? So these are two different
representations. And I want to connect
my representation here with my
representation here. So there's a very
simple way to do that, right? So let's
say that we start here. we go to the
continum. So this is what we do, right?
So we start here, we go to the
continuous version. So this is my first
operator. Go to the continuous version.
Then I apply my then I have my infinite
dimensional object which is right here.
So then I can apply to the finite
dimensional object. So this is a second
uh sort of chain in this composition.
Then I apply my G which is a third
chain. This is completely finite
dimensional. I have finite dimensional
result that I want to push back to
infinite dimensions. I do it with this
R. So now I have something which is in
infinite dimensions and I want to pull
back to my old finite dimensional object
or so this is this operator here. Now of
course everything relies on this error
being zero. Right? So going from finite
to infinite and then coming back from
infinite to finite uh this there is no
error in doing that. So when then you
can compose these two things together
and you can see that uh this is done
seamlessly and when there is an error
this will imply discrepancy between
resolutions because it will simply mean
that you cannot do this process anymore.
When you go from f from one finite
dimensional to the infinite dimensional
you make an error. It's possible that
they cancel out but in general they
don't and then when you go back to the
other finite dimensional there's another
error and these errors are additive.
Right? So the whole idea is that you
don't have uh you don't have this error.
You have a seamless integration between
these uh these two objects. Right? Uh so
far I I rushed a little bit but uh yeah
we are also running out of time. So did
you understand the basic concept here
that you want a very tight coupling
between infinite dimensions and finite
dimensions? The details have to be
worked out right. What is the infinite
dimensional space? what is the finite
dimension space? What is my encoding?
What is my reconstruction operator and
so on. But in general, if they exist,
you can see that you can go from one
dimension, one infinite, one finite
dimensional representation, discrete
representation to another discrete
representation seamlessly. Questions?
No, the abstract concept is clear. Okay.
So, let's try to do one example or shall
we take a break here?
Uh let's see how much of material do I
have to you know let's let's just uh
stop here because there's no point in
rushing because the next one requires a
little bit concentration little bit of
knowledge of signal processing we're
almost uh at the end so we can we can go
so the point is that we will check so
this is a nice theoretical concept but
uh as you can imagine CNN's and FNO they
don't satisfy this right because
otherwise we would be able to move
between one grid resolution and another
grid resolution seamlessly and then
we'll later on find out if you can
design any operator which can satisfy a
discrete machine learning algorithm
which can satisfy this property. Yes
requirement for resolution in targets
>> uh is this a strict no it's not it's
sufficient but it's not necessary
because these errors can cancel out
>> okay
>> right this is what I said that uh it's
it's clear I think it's almost necessary
but I don't think it's necessary yet
there needs more technical conditions
for this to be necessary because
remember that you can go from the finite
to the infinite dimension and make an
error of 10% % but then you go from
infinite to finite and you make another
error of 10%, but if these errors
exactly cancel there's a possibility
that by accident you can even learn it
but in general they're additive you know
you'll get error of 20%. So this is uh
this is how it is but this is sufficient
condition not a necessary condition.
further questions? No. If not, then we
stop here. Uh the tutorials are running
a bit bit ahead of us because they in
the next lecture we'll introduce we'll
we'll show that CNN's and FNOS's are not
satisfying these properties these nice
properties as expected. We also
understand why they don't satisfy these
properties. We find a corrective
mechanism and at least one example of
that which is CNO convolution neural
operator. And anyway in the tutorial
they will uh they will start with that.
So they they will introduce you to the
code of correlation operators. Okay.